NOT BE KIND TO THIS PATHETIC
IDIOT FROM CALIFORNIA
28TH CONGRESSIONAL DISTRICT.
FOX NEWS CONTRIBUTOR I’M A
FORMER CONSUL CERTAIN TREY
GOWDY.
I’M IMPRESSED, I ALWAYS KNEW YOU
WERE A PROSECUTOR THAT NEVER
LOST A CASE.
AS I READ PARTS OF THE 6,000
PAGES, I NEED SLEEP AND I AM
CRANKY TONIGHT.
BUT, I SEE THAT YOU GRILLED
ANDREW McCABE AT ONE POINT.
AT ONE POINT DID THE BUREAU ASK
YOU WHY DID YOU DO THIS
RESEARCH, WHO WERE YOU DOING IT
FOR, IS ANYONE PAYING YOU TO DO
IT?
WHY DID THOSE QUESTIONS COME UP?
HIS ANSWER, AM I READING THIS
CORRECTLY?
I DON’T KNOW.
IS THAT POSSIBLE AT THIS POINT?
DID THAT REALLY HAPPEN?
>> YEAH, IT HAPPENED.
WE SPENT A LONG TIME WITH ANDY
McCABE.
THE DOSSIER NOT ONLY WAS NOT
VERIFIED, THEY HAD NOT EVEN
BEGUN TO VERIFY IT.
IT WAS AFTER IT WAS USED,
GRANTED THEY USED IT IN COURT
PROCEEDING, BUT THEY HAD NOT
EVEN TAKEN THE FIRST STEP
TOWARDS TRYING TO VERIFY THAT.
LISTENING TO YOUR MONOLOGUE, IT
WASN’T JUST THAT WE ASK TO SUSAN
RICE AND SAMANTHA POWER AND BEN
RHODES AND SALLY YATES, WE
DIDN’T JUST SAY GIVE US ALL THE
EVIDENCE OF COLLUSION
COORDINATION AND CONSPIRACY.
I ASKED EVERY ONE OF THEM EVEN
IF IT’S HEARSAY, EVEN IF IT’S
SOMETHING YOU HEARD THAT YOU
DIDN’T BELIEVE, EVEN IF IT’S
INADMISSIBLE IN COURT, TELL ME
EVERYTHING YOU’VE EVER HEARD
ABOUT TRUMP, HIS CAMPAIGN, OR
EVEN THE GROUPIES IN THE HANGERS
ON IN HIS CAMPAIGN.
THERE WAS NOTHING.
MY EXPECTATIONS OF ADAM SCHIFF
ARE VERY LOW.
HE STILL DOESN’T MEET THEM BUT
THEY ARE VERY LOW.
MY EXPECTATIONS OF THE MEDIA WAS
A LITTLE BIT HIGHER, AND THEY
AIDED AND ABETTED HIM FOR THE
ENTIRE YEAR WE CONDUCTED THIS
INVESTIGATION.
>> Sean: THEY NEARLY
SUCCEEDED, TREY GOWDY.
THIS IS AN ATTEMPT COUPE, THEY
KNEW HE WAS LYING, WHY ISN’T HE
HELD TO THE SAME STANDARD.
McCABE TOLD YOU THEY DIDN’T
HAVE ANY EVIDENCE TYING
PAPADOPOULOS TO RUSSIA, THEY
WOULDN’T GET THE FISA
APPLICATION.
YOU ASKED SOME OF ABOUT HER ROLE
AS U.N. AMBASSADOR, AND THE SAME
AMBASSADOR RICE.
YOU CALLED HEARD THE LARGEST
UNMASK HER IN U.S. HISTORY.
WE WILL KEEP THEM UP ON THE
SCREEN, AS WE GET YOU.
>> I WILL TELL YOU, SAMANTHA
POWER EXPIRATION OUGHT TO SCARE
YOU.
I DIDN’T MAKE THOSE UNMASKING
REQUESTS, SOMEBODY MAY HAVE MADE
THEM BUT I DIDN’T MAKE THEM.
KEEP IN MIND, SOMEBODY UNMASKED
MICHAEL FLYNN’S NAME.
SOMEBODY UNMASKED HIS NAME AND
GAVE THAT PRESIDENT OBAMA.
IT WASN’T SALLY YATES, SHE
DIDN’T KNOW ABOUT IT.
THE D.C. MEDIA LOVES LEAKS, THEY
LIVE ON LAKES.
I WISH SOMEBODY WOULD LEAK TO
THEM WHO IT WAS THAT TOLD
PRESIDENT OBAMA THAT MICHAEL
FLYNN’S NAME WAS IN THAT
TRANSCRIPT.
>> Sean: DID ANYONE THAT YOU
INTERVIEWED, I WAS LOOKING FOR
YOUR INTERROGATION, YOU DID A
GREAT JOB BEHIND-THE-SCENES, A
LOT OF PEOPLE DID A GREAT JOB
BEHIND THE SCENES.
AT ANY POINT DID ANYBODY IN ANY
WAY SHAPE, MATTER, OR FORM EVER
CONFIRMED ANYTHING IN THE DIRTY
DOSSIER THAT HILLARY PAID FOR
THAT CHRISTOPHER STEELE
SUB-SOURCED IN FEBRUARY 2017
SAID WAS WRONG, BUT STILL WAS
USED IN A SCOPE MEMO BY ROD
ROSENSTEIN IN AUGUST OF 2017
LIKE EIGHT MONTHS LATER AND
STILL USED AS A BASIS FOR THE
FISA WARRANTS?
DID ANYONE EVER GIVE YOU ANY
JUSTIFICATION TO BELIEVE THERE
WAS ANY TRUTH IN THAT DIRTY
DOSSIER THAT HILLARY PAID FOR?
>> GLENN SIMPSON COULDN’T EVEN
DO IT.
HE’S A GPS OWNER, MICHAEL COHEN
WHO HATES THE PRESIDENT, HE SAID
THE DOSSIER IS A BUNCH OF LIES.
THIS IS SOMEBODY WHO HATES TRUMP
AND HE SAID IT IS A BUNCH OF
LIES.
GLENN SIMPSON BOUGHT AND PAID
FOR IT, HE COULDN’T VERIFY IT.
I CANNOT BELIEVE THE
UNITED STATES.
>> Sean: TREY GOWDY, YOU’VE
NEVER LOST A CASE IS A
PROSECUTOR.
I WOULD ARGUE THIS IS A CLEAR
AND PRESENT DANGER TO THE
UNITED STATES THAT A LIFE
DOSSIER THAT WAS NOT VERIFIED
WAS USED TO TAKE AWAY A GUY’S
CONSTITUTIONAL RIGHT, SPY ON A
PRESIDENTIAL CANDIDATE, DEEP
INTO THE PRESIDENCY, AND THEY
ALL KNEW IT WAS A LIKE TREY
GOWDY.
HOW CAN THAT HAPPEN IN THE GREAT
COUNTRY OF THE UNITED STATES OF
AMERICA WITH OUR
U.S. CONSTITUTION?
CAN YOU EXPEND THAT?
>> THERE ARE THREE GROUPS THAT
PROVIDE ACCOUNTABILITY HERE.
THE VOTERS, THEY HAVE A CHANCE
TO SAY WHETHER OR NOT ADAM
SCHIFF FLEX THEIR VALUES.
THERE IS THE MEDIA, TOTALLY
ABDICATED THEIR ROLE AND THEN
THE EXECUTIVE BRANCH,
UNFORTUNATELY WE ARE WAITING ON
JOHN DURHAM BECAUSE THE MEDIA
NOT ONLY DO THEY NOT PROVIDE
SCRUTINY OVER ADAM SCHIFF, THEY
AIDED AND ABETTED HIM.
POLITICO, THE HILL,
"WASHINGTON POST","
"NEW YORK TIMES," I WILL COME ON
AND GIVE YOU THE REPORTERS NAMES
SOMETIME.
THE REPORTERS WHO SAT THERE AND
HELPED ADAM SCHIFF PERPETRATE
THIS FRAUD.
NEXT TIME I’M WITH YOU, I WILL
GIVE YOU THE NAMES OF THEM.
>> Sean: WE KNOW HE KNEW THE
TRUTH, CAN HE BE HELD
ACCOUNTABLE LEGALLY?
YOUR GREAT ATTORNEY.
>> NO, HE HAS IMMUNITY.
THE ONLY ACCOUNT ABILITY SHOULD
COME FROM COURT.
LET THE VOTERS THROW HIM OUT.
THEY CAN DO BETTER IN CALIFORNIA